هذه السيده اقدمت على فعله شنيعه لا يمكن
ان يتصورها عقل وقعت احداثها في باراغواي
باعت طفلتها ذات ثلاثه اعوام لتاجر مخدرات
مقابل ما قيمته 12 دولار من الكوكايين غير
ابهه بما سيفعله ذلك الرجل بطفلتها لم تكن
الطفله البريئه لوزميده تعلم عندما
ايقظتها والدتها في منتصف الليل انها تعيش
اخر لحظات في حياتها قبل ان تغتصب وتخنق
حتى الموت كاميرات المراقبه التقطت لوز
وهي تحاول الفكاك من تاجر المخدرات بينما
يصطحبها بعيدا خارج منزلها الام البالغه
من العمر 42 عاما وتدعى اوريلياس اليناس
ابلغت الشرطه باختفاء طفلتها لكنها اعترفت
بجريمتها لاحقا الجيران عثروا على جثه
الطفل الصغيره في احد المنازل المهجوره
كما اعترف تاجر المخدرات باغتصاب الطفله
وقتلها